bonjour à tous ça fait presque trente
ans maintenant que je fais de la
génétique
j'ai toujours été étonné et frappé par
le fait que lorsqu'on fait visiter les
laboratoires un certain nombre de
personnes n'osent pas entrer dans le
laboratoire et sont impressionnés et
reste sur le pas de la porte
comme si la génétique était dangereuse
et n'existait que dans les laboratoires
ne faisait pas partie de notre monde est
donc l'histoire ce qui m'amène ici c'est
de vous expliquer que la génétique est
en train de vivre une révolution et que
c'est une activité typiquement humaine
qui nous a amenés où on est au jour
d'aujourd'hui est que depuis maintenant
une petite centaine d'années on est
vraiment passés à une autre vitesse la
génétique étudie le vivant et le vivant
faut pas l'oublier c'est une propriété
qui au jour d'aujourd'hui reste unique
et est cantonné à notre planète la terre
autrement dit tous les organismes
vivants et nous mêmes sommes figés sur
cette terre qui a un petit peu comme
notre vaisseau spatial qui tourne dans
l'univers la génétique étudie le
transfert de l'information d'un
organisme vivant à sa descendance et des
caractères de ces organismes vers les
descendants la vie à moduler de manière
très très important la chimie de la
terre l'air que vous respirez dans cette
salle et que je respire dans cette salle
et plus particulièrement l'oxygène qu'il
contient qui est essentiel à notre vie a
été créée par la vie par les organismes
qui sont capables de faire de la
photosynthèse
c'est à dire transporter et transformer
l'énergie solaire pour leur croissance
et cette réaction et mais un dégagement
d'oxygène et c'est oxygène vient de là
autrement dit si nous vivons au jour
d'aujourd'hui c'est parce que deux
organismes ont vécu avant et on crée
l'oxygène pour nous équilibre de la
terre et de son atmosphère en oxygène
est toujours régulée par ces mécanismes
là et plus particulièrement par les
micro algues qui se trouve sur les
océans et qui font toujours
qui font cette réaction pour générer de
l'oxygène elles ne font pas pour générer
l'oxygène pour nous le font pour leur
propre vie et nous en profitons derrière
elle la vit également modifier
fondamentalement la géographie de
certains endroits de la terre les atolls
par exemple sont construits par des
coraux qu'ils peuvent être des
constructions ou vraiment gigantesque en
mer sur lequel de la vie vient ensuite
s'est incrusté comme par exemple des
végétaux et donc ces colonisés par une
autre vie nous avons un exemple assez
remarquable de la vie qui se construit
sur la vie alors cette vie elle a évolué
sur la terre il a connu différentes
formes avec les très emblématique
dinosaures qui ont aujourd'hui disparu
du crétacé l'aider au crétacé qui ont
aujourd'hui disparu
enfin ils ont disparu par tout à fait en
fait leur reste et qui n'ont pas été
complètement des composés sont enfouis
dans le sous sol de la terre et forme le
charbon le pétrole et le gaz
en fait quand vous remplissez votre
réservoir de réservoirs de voitures et
de l'essence de pétrole en fait vous
utilisez une partie de dinosaures et des
molécules qui viennent du fin fond
d'histoire de la vie il faut toujours se
souvenir que de nouveaux on est en lien
avec le passé et une activité vivant le
plus vivant à une influence extrêmement
importante
le vivant est apparue il ya 3,5
milliards d'années
et quand on regarde au jour
d'aujourd'hui on a des animaux
formidable extrêmement bien adaptés à
leur environnement qui peuvent être les
airs les maires ou la terre mais il ne
faut pas oublier que beaucoup
d'organismes vivants sont invisibles à
nos yeux sont visibles pour nous que le
ville trois siècles l'invention du
microscope
ce sont les micro organismes dans
quelques grammes de terre il ya des
millions de micro organismes qui vivent
là et qui génèrent des molécules et qui
contribue à l'équilibré de notre planète
et de notre environnement
nous sommes apparus il ya 5 millions
d'années et on a une caractéristique
très importante si vous y réfléchissez
on est le seul être vivant est la seule
espèce qui occupe aujourd'hui
l'entièreté la surface de la terre on
trouve des hommes depuis les pôles
jusqu'à l'équateur et dans tous les
types d'environnement ceci est uni que
jamais trouvé un ours blanc en pyrénées
ni inversement
donc on a cette spécificité d'avoir
conquis l'ensemble de la surface de la
terre pour notre expansion au début
l'homme vives de pêche de chasse de
cueillette et donc ils vivaient dans la
forêt était fortement dépendant de la
nature de ce fait au néolithique il ya
dix mille ans il a décidé de se
sédentariser et en se sédentarisent ans
il s'est extrait de la pression de
sélection et de l'évolution naturelle en
se protégeant et il a amené avec lui des
animaux et des plantes et donc il a
retiré ses animaux et ces plantes de
l'évolution naturelle pour les faire
évoluer à son avantage par des
croisements diriger autrement dit ce que
je suis en train de vous décrire c'est
l'agriculture et c'est l'élevage
il a réussi extrêmement bien à faire ce
travail bien évidemment de manière
totalement empirique il faut se rappeler
que néolithique commence avant l'arrivée
de l'écriture donc l'homme était
incapable d'écrire et de lire à cette
époque et faisait déjà de la génétique
et donc il a croisé par exemple les
moutons pour produire plus de l'ain et
pouvoir se vêtir chose essentielle quand
on veut conquérir de nouveaux
environnements
il a également domestique et le ver à
soie qui produit la soie et donc du
tissu pour ses besoins l'a fait la même
chose avec les plantes en fête le blé et
le maïs quand ils sont à l'état naturel
ne sont que des espèces d'herbes folles
qui sont incapables de nourrir le
moindre êtres humains par des
croisements l'homme les a rendus quelque
part des machines vivent là produire de
la nourriture
et c'est grâce à ces travaux qui
s'appelait pas des travaux mais les
croisements que on a peut être et qu'on
peut être aujourd'hui c'est 3 milliards
d'êtres humains sur terre il s'est pas
arrêté à domestiquer les organismes
macroscopique
il a également domestiques et des micro
organismes comme la levure et donc il
s'est servi de la levure 120 de l'avoir
pour faire de la bière du vin des
fromages du pain et donc c'est également
les domestication de la chimie de la vie
au propre avantage l'être humain et
c'est ça qui lui a permis vraiment
d'aller toujours plus loin et de
toujours avancer
donc il fait vraiment construit sur les
capacités de la vie et en attirer un
maximum davantage également dans ses
déplacements
qu'on pense à part et trivial jour
d'aujourd'hui on prend sa voiture on va
un endroit à un autre
ça n'a évidemment jamais été le cas que
très récemment si on veut se déplacer il
faut avoir un animal pour vous aider à
vous déplacer donc l'homme à élever et
croiser des animaux il a sélectionné
pour ses propres déplacements dans nos
contrées le cheval cheval de trait
cheval de course dans les zones
arctiques
les chiens de traîneaux pouvoir tirer le
traîneau dans des zones extrêmement
aride et dans les déserts le dromadaire
tout ça ce sont des animaux qui ont été
sélectionnés par l'homme pour leur
capacité à toujours l'aider à aller de
l'avant
évidemment nous ne sont plus des
éleveurs et ne sont plus en contact avec
les animaux de ferme mais on a nos
animaux domestiques et donc les plus
populaires sont le chat et le chien
si vous réfléchissez le chien sauvage
comme on dit en génétique celle un loup
est donc l'homme les a croisés pour au
début faire une fonctionnalité se
défendre
contrôler les moutons et ensuite c'est
devenu plus au jour d'aujourd'hui des
croisements hobby quand on pense au
chihuahua en fait à chihuahua descend du
loup et donc il fait partie de la même
espèce
mais c'est l'homme qu'il a créée par des
croisements dire tout quiconque a un
chien de race c'est bien que son chien a
un pedigree qui doit être suivie et
toujours croisé il ya des éleveurs
spécialisés
même chose pour les chats fait les gens
demander mais le ch a servi à quoi fait
initialement le ch a mangé les souris
qu'il allait manger de grains d'êtres
humains et ensuite au jour d'aujourd'hui
on le croise pour faire des espèces de
peluches qui sont intéressantes pour les
enfants et pour tout le monde donc la
génétique fait vraiment partie de notre
quotidien
quand on y pense de plus près et quand
on regarde son animal domestique et donc
cette génétique qui a créé ces animaux
il faut de nouveau se rendre compte
qu'elle n'était absolument pas dans les
laboratoires ni fait par des professeurs
elle était totalement empirique les
éleveurs recroisait les animaux qui
avait des caractéristiques intéressantes
l'efsc sélectionnés et les maintenaient
et c'est cette activité la génétique
empirique qui a permis à l'espèce
humaine de prendre le dessus occuper
l'ensemble de la planète et être
aujourd'hui ces trois milliards d'êtres
humains
cet empirisme a été terminée en 1944
seulement où le professeur avery a
découvert que la molécule qui faisait le
transfert des caractères d'un individu à
l'autre
l adn donc celui qui a mis en évidence
en 1944 dix ans plus tard
watson et crick ont découvert la
structure de l'adn
donc c'est cette double hélice dont on
parle beaucoup qui en fait contient le
code de tout ce qui est vivant sur terre
et donc cette molécule est celle qui
réside où réside le secret de la ville
et le transfert de l'information d'une
génération à l'autre
ce code a été étudié un petit peu comme
le code morse et donc au jour
d'aujourd'hui qu'on a une séquence adn
on est capable de la lire et dans neuf
rés quelle sera la propriété qu'elle
transfère pas toujours simplement les
zones qui code pour les protéines qui
sont finalement les tout ce qui fait
votre peau vos cheveux fédérations des
protéines elles sont codées par vos
jambes et on est capable en lisant les
quatre lettres de l'alphabet génétique
ga atc de savoir pour quelle acides
aminés et le code et tout s'est encore
accélérée à la fin du siècle passé où
l'homme a mis au point des machines qui
lui permettent de séquences et donc lire
le code de manière automatique en 2003
le séquençage du génome humain a été
rendu public
il avait demandé dix ans de travaux des
milliards d'investissements et on avait
un seul gène ou au jour d'aujourd'hui je
peux vous annoncer si vous ne savez pas
c'est que si vous en voyez un peu un
échantillon de 200 vous aurez votre code
génétique dans les quatre cinq jours et
ceci pour 1000 euros
donc tout le monde va avoir accès tout
le monde a accès potentiel toxique a à
son propre génome et on est capable de
lire l'ensemble des génomes de la vie le
même la même personne grec 20 heures qui
était un des moteurs du séquençage
génome humain que vous avez vus à bill
clinton
en 2006 la même personne avec ses
équipes en 2010 a annoncé et réussi à
synthétiser l'ensemble des gens d'un
microorganisme donc avec ses collègues
ils ont écrit le coach et à attester
d'un microorganisme en copiant
évidemment la vie parce qu'on ne connaît
pas tout il a mis son e-mail et l'âme et
de la poésie dans le génome et ensuite
il a été le réintégrer donc l'organisme
que vous voyez là derrière moi est le
premier organisme construit par l'être
humain en laboratoire au niveau
génétique
ça a déjà des impacts énormes surtout
dans notre santé donc on peut
aujourd'hui détecter les maladies
génétiques on peut faire des médicaments
d'une nouvelle génération ondes est en
train d'améliorer grandement la santé
humaine ce qui permet de toujours vivre
plus âgés mais l'autre point important
c'est que ça va modifier la chimie
plutôt de partir des anciennes molécules
du dinosaure dont je vous ai parlé on va
pouvoir refaire faire par des
micro-organismes des molécules qu'ils
font naturellement mais beaucoup trop
lentement que pour arriver à l'état
industriel et donc on est face à une
révolution que l'on appelle dans les
cercles d'initiés la bioéconomie c'est à
dire l'utilisation du vivant à des fins
de remplacement d'autres approches
utilisées jusqu'à présent
évidemment on en parle beaucoup ces
techniques là ne vont remplacer
l'utilisation des énergies fossiles et
donc ont le mérite de ne pas remettre
dans l'atmosphère du co2 et donc sont
moins impactante à ce niveau là et ont
donc moins d'impact sur les changements
climatiques
il reste des challenge c'est bien comme
ça je peux continuer généticien c'est le
fait que comme le vivant vient d'une
évolution il est extrêmement compliqué
c'est donc au jour d'aujourd'hui on est
les scientifiques en train de tenter de
comprendre comment le vivent fonctionne
dans ses détails pour vraiment pouvoir
l'un généré vraiment au mieux de ce que
l'on veut faire dans nos industries du
futur alors simplement pour résumer
c'est simplement dire que à partir de la
découverte de l'adn et de la
compréhension chimiques de ce qui est
notre code et le code universel
génétique
la seconde partie du 20e siècle a
vraiment vu s'accumuler les notions de
base le 21e siècle c'est clair c'est le
design rationnelle et donc on est sortis
de l'empirisme ont commencé à écrire des
organismes vivants à partir du code pour
en faire des fonctions nécessaires
alors mon petit moonshot à moi c'est
pour vous dire que si de manière
empirique
l'homme a réussi à coloniser l'ensemble
de sa planète
il l'a fait grâce à la génétique
empirique
s'il veut un jour quitter sa planète est
allé vers d'autres terres il ya peu de
chance que ses autres univers et la même
composition chimique que celui qu'on
cherche
et donc il faudra design et étudier la
génétique à nouveau mais c'est génétique
rationnelle pour pouvoir aller coloniser
et quitter la planète sur lequel au jour
d'aujourd'hui on est toujours bloqué et
donc j'espère que la prochaine fois que
vous avez l'occasion de visiter un
laboratoire de génétique mais vous aurez
pas peur de passer la porte d'entrée et
que vous irez discuter les généticiens
et je remercie beaucoup